Chris what is going on with the hair
under the chin I'm like what is that all
about it's completely under his chin
it's his oh yeah
let me see you I've always had this
quiet down for a minute let me look you
over
your head
oh my God Chris she's right what are you
talking about your chin has no hair on
it it's all under your chin it's like a
neck beard that's not true that's so not
true
in here I do not listen to me lift up
your chin
what I would do is change either the
lights in your apartment or uh just
shave shave underneath Zoom Zoom it's on
Zoom it's the lighting is not on the
zoom and there's no lighting under my
chin yes that's called in the same
facial hair for years and all of a
sudden I have a neck beard yeah it's a
neck beard you got to do something about
it don't get defensive
that's me no no Robin's right I don't
want to be commented on
turn
your head to the left
dude it's all under oh you've got this
thick massive amount of hair all under
your chin like under not on your chin
but under on the neck I have hair here
too you just can't see it it's lighter
and shave this down shave this down and
keep that uh if you want to have some
stubble you understand you taught me to
grow out the hair a little bit mine from
you but your hair under your neck is too
thick thick it's like a big massive
Brillo pad underneath your chin it's
like the Amish beard I'm telling you
dude it's growing all underneath the
chin not on your chin it is growing on
the chin you're not seeing it because of
the lighting it's making it's an
illusion or an illusion
all right there's an Amish Gentleman on
the phone wants a comment on uh Chris's
beard yes sir
I can't believe I'm using a phone but I
wanted to say we could use you on the
farm Chris
[Laughter]
you're using a phone the whole premise
is [ __ ] stupid sorry I haven't bought
a barrel that we could use and you know
would you like to make some cool
furniture